we just keep learning more and more
about connections between Russia and
Donald Trump's campaign staff and now
pulling in Trump son-in-law and senior
adviser jared kushner who by his own
right had two meetings with Russian
officials in December the first meeting
we already knew about that's the meeting
that involved Mike Flynn and Russian
ambassador sergey kiss react the second
meeting is the one that we're only now
finding out about was between Kushner
and Sergey Gourcuff the chairman of the
Russian government National Development
Bank nesha khanam bank nash economy bank
i don't know exactly how it's pronounced
a little bit about that bank that bank
has been under us sanctions since 2014
when Russia invaded Crimea the FSB uses
this Bank to conceal spies in 2015 a new
york-based employee of the bank was
convicted of spying on the US and trying
to recruit new york city residents the
spy for Russia the bank provided cover
for the spy and also paid for his
defense the White House has now
officially confirmed that the meeting
between kushner and the bank took place
but that the meeting was not of any
significance and didn't have any
consequences like every single one of
the other dozens of connections between
Trump his associates in Russia none have
any significant consequences how silly
is that argument you would have to
believe that dozens of meetings are
happening with no purpose or outcome
whatsoever why is everybody wasting
their time right not to mention is that
what Russian bank chairman like to do
with their spare time travel to the u.s.
to hang out with representatives of
presidential campaigns and talk about
nothing achieve nothing and get nothing
done who believes that these meetings
are of no consequence yet it's always
what the White House says about the
meetings between the Trump team and
Russian officials they didn't talk about
anything important nothing came of it
period it's weird how often Russian
officials are having face-to-face
meetings with Trump officials which they
are reticent to admit even took place
but insist nothing of note was discussed
you'd have to be a [ __ ] to believe that
well Serge a kiss Lee act
russian ambassador he's the most popular
guy in Washington aliens isn't he that
will that gets me to my other question
which is were there did we see this
frequency of meetings between Trump
officials and officials of many other
countries like give me the full list of
other countries where there wasn't maybe
one meeting but there were where there
were this number of meetings I am not
aware of any country and that also is
part of the story and you would imagine
it would be countries like England and
France and Canada our closest allies
rather than a country that's honestly an
adversary the Russian government yeah or
at least was our biggest adversary
according to the 2012 Republican
presidential candidate Mitt Romney an
allegation that very few Republicans
disagreed with at the time and again
there's the incident and then there's
the cover up until this week the White
House had only admitted to one of
kushner's meeting with the Russian of
meetings with the Russian ambassador if
the White House lied about the second
kushner meeting with the bank chairman
how many other meetings are still
undisclosed every week we find out the
White House has been hiding the
existence of meetings do you believe for
a second Pat that now we finally know
all the meetings that took place I don't
for a second more will come out and
that's why I think it's important to get
some of these people under oath and you
have safai because they may pull a jeff
Sessions they may perjure themselves
even on unforced errors well Virginia
Senator Mark Warner announced that jared
kushner is going to be questioned about
these meetings in an upcoming Senate
Intelligence Intelligence Committee
hearing this now makes 77 Trump
associates that will be testifying in
front of the Senate Intelligence
Committee kushner is I would argue the
closest to trump to be implicated in the
Russia connections but I want to take a
step back for a second i think that the
willingness with which Kushner has come
forward and said he would talk to the
Senate Intelligence panel I think it's a
setup in the sense that he may not
really have that much to say he is
probably being selected because he could
maybe go up there and be totally honest
and not really say anything that
incriminating and this may be a very
calculated thing that is being done
because okay let's send Jared he'll be
super open and he
the guy who really doesn't have as much
to hide I don't think that his
willingness is he's super willing to
testify all of a sudden is because he's
the guy who's guiltiest in this whole
thing well it's possible because while
he is Donald Trump senior policy advisor
or senior adviser to the president we
have those rules he's also Donald Trump
son-in-law yes indeed and got a security
clearance much later than the rest of
the people in his cabinet can you
remember off hand if the son-in-law is
part is subject to the anti nepotism no
it's not it's not it's only direct
family members interesting interesting
we'll continue following it will see
what jared kushner ultimately has to say
today's episode of the david pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
I glasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five day home try-on from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like an an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
three hundred dollars for prescription
glasses with Warby Parker they started
just 95 bucks mine cost that including
lenses and for every pair sold they give
a pair to someone in need so to try the
five pairs and support the david pakman
show go to Warby Parker trial com /t DPS